de gaulle qui était ce qu'en reste-t-il
oubli a difference dévotion
est il seulement un personnage
historique en fouillant la poussière du
siècle ou au contraire est il encore
vivant dans nos esprits comme une ombre
qui impose toujours sa présence
en pensant à ce qui arrivera par de
gaulle a disparu je vous dis ceci ce qui
est à redouter à mon sens ce n'est pas
le vide politique c'est plutôt le
trop-plein
mesdames messieurs je vous remercie pas
tenable
il est 9 heures 39 la général de gaulle
est mort ce matin à colombelles je n'ai
pas d'autres détails je pense que dans
quelques minutes aura peut-être par nos
confrères les agents souvient par nos
correspondants d'autres détails
en plus on se
vous savez lorsque devant les membres il
fallait d'abord faire la liste de tout
ce qu'ils valaient pas faire comme
dessein pas de naturellement pas
dessinée de gaulle naturellement pas de
plaisanterie naturellement pas de
kabangu
donc un dessin sans paroles donc
qu'est-ce que c'était c'était quelque
chose de grand qui était tombé j'ai
pensé d'abord à une colonne colonnes par
terre est brisée puis j'ai pensé qu'un
arbre s'était plus spectaculaire
graphiquement j'ai donc laissé d'arbres
moi j'ai fait un arbre et un jour à la
télé madame peu de temps après madame
baudrier interviewait monsieur malo qui
avait écrit ses chênes qu'on abat et
elle lui a dit pourquoi ce titre alors
il a dit elle vers de victor hugo et
puis elle décembre faisant
et depuis tout le monde me dit tu sais
pas dessiner les chaînes mais mon frère
j'ai jamais voulu dessiner un chêne
c'est pas un chêne ça c'est un arbre
françaises français
le général de gaulle est mort
la france veut
la nuit et la pluie enveloppait l'arc de
triomphe
lorsque des milliers d'hommes et de
femmes se sont trouvés réunis dans une
même pensée
entre l'appel de juin 40 et ce jour de
deuil national
tant d'événements retentissants ont
marqué une histoire de la france et la
vie de charles de gaulle que sa légende
ne pourra que se prolonger
très loin dans l'avenir
le général de gaulle était mort il y
avait un rassemblement à l'étoile
c'était une semblait que c'était ma
place et je crois qu'on a été nombreux à
penser la même chose
c'est terrible une foule silencieuse ça
me prend aux tripes
et
il n'y avait pas de bruit on sentait que
ils avaient perdu leur père
à colombey les deux églises ses obsèques
se sont déroulées selon le cérémonial
qu'il avait fixé dès 1952
les hommes et les femmes de france
pourront s'ils le désirent faire à ma
mémoire l'honneur d'accompagner mon
corps jusqu'à sa dernière demeure
mais c'est dans le silence que je
souhaite qu'il y soit peau
avant le 9 novembre 70 colombey les deux
églises étaient déjà un village
différent des autres
depuis la mort du général de gaulle
collombat est devenu un des hauts lieux
du souvenir
pourquoi vient-il ses visiteurs me
touristes me bellemare ils sont plus de
cent mille cette année à se rendre à
colombey-les-deux-églises
depuis sa mort
la popularité du général de gaulle n'a
cessé de croître au point qu'aujourd'hui
trois français sur quatre le place en
tête des personnages qui ont marqué
l'histoire du 20e siècle
dans la mémoire de tous de gaulle est
d'abord l'homme du 18 juin le général
rebelle
visionnaire qui en 1940 avait compris le
sens véritable du dernier conflit
mondial
actuellement à colombelles et l église
en france ac
c'est la place
vrai pour lui c'est à dire y atteint la
terre le ciel
avec les niais gb soleil
pourquoi pas elle non plus est-ce que je
peux le prendre comme un souvenir
merci vous pouvez sur des produits pour
moi c'est un objet symbolise de nos
motivations attaché et je la mettrais
dans mon dans mon bureau
les scandales financiers pour moi le
général de gaulle n'est pas seulement un
dirigeant français
c'est un dirigeant mondial universel
je pense que de gaulle était tendue
comme une fois le 4 au 5 % de notre
siècle
qui changent et les destins
france est clairement et peut-être
mondiale à la même temps
dans la capacité
personal sans aucun doute qu'ils étaient
parmi les plus grands
avec bandits
avec mortes tombent lénine churchill in
bloom ou semaines en juillet des zones
d'où j'étais le premier misère
étrangères des pays membres de la
communauté être si officiellement par
mao ils étaient seulement surpris
comment home accueille en me disant
pourquoi avez vous laissé mourir le
général de gaulle c'était une des très
rares personnes que je voulais
rencontrer il voyait encore la france à
travers de gaulle quand tu évolues mort
on a dit
qu'ils aillent avoir un grand service
pour sa mémoire dans la cathédrale
d'accra yade a demandé à l'ambassadeur
de france de venir prendre la parole
alors
mais cette dame de france a parlé
d'abord en français mais bien aux
personnes de comprenez il a recommencé
son discours en anglais elle ce
moment-là tout cet énorme cathédrale je
sais bien que c'était en afrique s'est
mis à sangloter à pleurer ces gens qui
avaient qu avait jamais qui avait jamais
vu de gaulle de l'armee qu'elle ya ce
qu'ils avaient eh ben il pleurait il
semblait
si de gaulle a survécu dans la mémoire
de ses contemporains il est mort pour
les nouvelles générations
pour les jeunes c'est déjà de l'histoire
ancienne mais comme toute histoire il
faut la découvrir la prendre c'est dans
les collèges sur les bancs des écoles au
hasard d'une promenade qui le rencontre
le général de gaulle bon on en rit
landeron entendu parler dans leur
scolarité et c'est vrai que pour les
élèves c'est un personnage qui déjà ne
connaissent pas quand il arrive un élève
de 15 ans par exemple la moitié c'est
vraiment jamais entendu parler du
général de gaulle moi général de gaulle
actuellement à londres j'invite les
officiers soldats français qui se
trouvent en territoire britannique ou
qui viendraient à s'y trouver avec ou
sans leurs armes j'invite les ingénieurs
et les ouvriers croyons que l'honneur
des peintres et
consiste à continuer la guerre aux côtés
de leurs alliés et nous sommes résolus à
le faire
nous espérons qu'un jour
une pâte mécanique supérieure
nous permettra d'avoir la victoire
et de délivrer la patrie on a perdu une
bataille on n'a surtout pas perdu la
guerre rien n'est perdu parce que le
conflit va obligatoirement se
mondialiser il apparaît d'abord comme un
résistant parce que les élèves qui
connaissent le général de gaulle le
connaissent comme un résistant donc
c'est vrai qu'on insiste énormément sur
le rôle qu'il a joué dans la seconde
guerre mondiale il apparaît comme étant
l'homme de la résistance qu'elle était
en convent employé ici il faut s'unir
oui il faut résister
la france était devenue un état de non
droit
donc il a fallu loup combattre le
gouvernement de pétain mais combattre on
il ne suffit pas il fallait aussi donner
l'exemple par exemple et bien la
résistance française a toujours pris un
soin féroce on peut dire de faire en
sorte que ces actes ne nuisent pas à la
population et ce souci permanent à
former les individus à des comportements
complètement nouveau il quand on fait
quand on pratique de tels actes de tels
comportements pendant un temps long
l'organisme l'individu prend l'habitude
et nous avons donc fabriqué des
individus dont la mentalité dont
l'éthique et dans les comportements
étaient
vont pour la société française le 30
juin 240 je me présente au général de
gaulle j'avais entendu la conclusion de
l'appel du 18 juin il y avait alors une
structure frêle mais française je
m'attendais à entendre la répétition de
l'appel et bien voici textuellement les
mots que le général de gaulle a
prononcée devant moi si hitler avait dû
venir à londres il y serait déjà
cette guerre est une guerre mondiale il
ne dit pas cette guerre sera une guerre
mondiale il dit cette guerre est une
guerre mondiale elle est par conséquent
un problème terrible mais résolue il
restera mené du bon côté non pas des
français mais la france
on a peu à peu compris que cet homme qui
était un noble général de gaulle qui
était un militaire d' acte il est donc
quand même porté la séquelle de l'échec
de l'armée française de 40 était un
homme qui était car est une valeur qui
était estimable et l'apparition du
général giraud sur la scène politique
lorsque les américains ont occupé
l'afrique du nord début novembre 1940
deux contres de gaulle autrement dit on
rejeter celui qui avait été le premier
combattant pour y mettre un général à
cinq étoiles qui était certainement fort
honorable mais dans la résistance à ce
moment là ne voulait strictement pas
elle ne voulait pas qu'on lui impose un
homme qu'elle ne connaissait pas et donc
à ce moment là il ya eu un basculement
de la résistance toute entière vers de
gaulle et à ce moment là effectivement
on a parlé de gauche
[Musique]
henri giraud
sa popularité posthume de gaulle la doit
sans doute au caractère exceptionnel de
son aventure à son combat solitaire il
lutte même contre son propre camp pour
rester fidèle à la tâche qu'il s'est
assigné durant la guerre il affronte le
président des états unis qui le tient
pour un apprenti dictateur et en
novembre 1942 les américains veulent t20
c'est de gaulle
les contacter
la séduction que de gaulle exerce sur
les français provient aussi de ce qu'il
est un personnage inclassable
à ce titre son premier voyage officiel
aux états unis durant l'été 1944 en
valeur de symbole de gaulle accueilli
froidement washington est ovationné à
new york dans les quartiers populaires
qu'il visite en compagnie du maire
démocrate sur l eau la guardia
et
quel autre vol
entre
[Applaudissements]
new
kaupthing
france
yu jianhua
ostberg ford avait ribéry ou et non au
stand by ce ne veut rien dire
[Applaudissements]
ice cube élèments miss thomert à niort
oyo
exceptionnel et
coffrets réceptions
bourgoin toulon rôle ils auront honte
after this
could you sérieuse au look to you men
and women brooklyn 11 démocratie on se
libérer trois pistolets gaujac to you
love tout nous ayons un to american pipe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
historiquement on peut dire que de
gaulle est l'homme du salut quand tout
est perdu et il est l'homme de la
grandeur quand tout est sauvé de gaulle
a toujours encouragé les mythes
nationaux ce mythe de la france
résistante dans son immense majorité de
même que dans les années 60 les succès
économiques vont être utilisé comme un
mythe mobilisateur pour faire croire les
français à cette mission de la france
qui se poursuit à la grandeur possible
qui doit être maintenue
comment les français aurait-il oublié à
la libération de paris et le sacre
populaire que de gaulle reçoit en ce
jour peu d'hommes dans l'histoire ont
reçu une telle consécration la
fascination que de gaulle suscite chez
nos contemporains doit aussi au
caractère pour le moins inhabituel de sa
carrière de retour à paris il installe
le gouvernement provisoire de la
république française à ce titre il
exerce les fonctions de chef d'état mais
au bout de 18 mois refusant d'accepter
la prédominance des partis politiques il
quitte le pouvoir en 1946 il ne reste
pas longtemps silencieux dans un
discours retentissant il dit ce que doit
être selon lui la constitution de la
france
c'est cette conception qu'il appliquera
en 1959 quand il fondera la vème
république
notre histoire
réfléchissez-y bien
c'est l'alternance des immense douleur
d'un peuple dispersé et des grandeurs
fécond
d'une nation groupé
i mois
sous l'égide d'un état fort aujourd'hui
nous en sommes certains
il n'y aura pas de victoire des rennais
excepté
pour la carte et et pour la fermeté qui
sont au total
toujours les abysses et suprême et d'une
étrange
les institutions
y environ la france
verse aux saluts et vers son renouveau
dans l'état républicain vive la
république vive la porte le jour va
venir
où notre peuple
eh ben non
un cadre malfatti ce peuple ce peuple
scott c'est à dire la mince immense et
français se rassemblera sur la planche
il est temps que se forme et que
s'organise
le rassemblement du peuple français
il en a fait d'éviter surtout les
premiers mails puis chastel aimons
tous les coins qu'il allait qui est
important est partie du service d'ordre
qu'elle ait
empêché genre d'approché trop près parce
qu'il était bien gentil longeard mais il
écoutait pas tellement ce qu'on élyséen
il voulait bien qu'on écoute ce qu'ils
disent lui mais pas nous passer il m'est
libéré avec alix pourquoi fallait qu'il
a il faut les à penser ces grandes
pattes au dessus pour aller serrer les
mains mais comme bien venir un jour mon
général un quelqu'un qui vous balancent
une grande attente où il pensait
[Musique]
pour lutter contre la quatrième
république de gauche créé en 1947 le
rassemblement du peuple français qui se
veut un mouvement ouvert à tous
dépassant les clivages politiques et
sociaux de la société en 1953 après
l'échec électoral du rpf le général de
gaulle se retire à la boisserie
propriété achetée dans les années 30 il
écrit alors ses mémoires de guerre c'est
la traversée du désert
[Musique]
mais
l'avis de bolden a t elle été marquée à
la fois par les alternatives très forte
d'actions
de mise en silence
bon qu'est ce qui se passe quand nouveau
leur temps à caumont bay regarde ce
grand or is an excellent bois ces forêts
etc qui reprend le large les rôles
retrouve ce qui est important pour lui
qui va nous montrer qui va réaliser en
58 et par la suite
moi je passion
si on accepte de
nous arrêter de réfléchir de on peut
tous trouvé cette récente d'humanité en
nous
[Musique]
le 13 mai 1958 une révolte en faveur de
l'algérie française éclatent à alger
elle menace l'existence même de la 4ème
république et pour bien des français de
gaulle apparaît à nouveau comme l'homme
providentiel images mythologie qui
conserve aujourd'hui dans notre histoire
mais vaincu
probable des événements
au
moment où on le rend pas
je pourrais servir le pays ni cn je
faisais de la résistance c'est à dire
que pour moi c'était un mythe heures ont
cassé le portrait de pétain on le
remplacer par celui de de gaulle parce
que comme on chantait au lieu de chanter
maréchal nous voilà enchanté général
nous voilà car de gaulle c'est la france
c'est la france c'est de gaulle donc
c'était la france mais je dois dire que
ce qui a changé tout c'est le coup de
force du 13 mai 58 bien sûr l'histoire
s'écrit autrement aujourd'hui parce
qu'il ya eu largement le large
légitimation de de 2 go le suffrage
universel tout cela mais le 13 mai 58 je
me trouvais au forum d'un g j'ai vu les
machines à écrire volet des étages et
entendu crier vive de gaulle et 48
heures plus tard
bloqué à alger comme avocats du fln
j'étais arrêté par ces mêmes
parachutistes qui criaient vive de
gaulle donc pour moi de gaulle était
l'homme du coup de force des masses sont
anxieuses et la situation exige des
décisions rapides à paris deux cent
mille manifestants viennent place de la
république exprimé leur crainte de voir
le général de gaulle abolir les libertés
républicaines
[Musique]
oui
que j'aie jamais à san siro rep
universités publiques fondamentales je
lisais 1re étape et il ya eu une seconde
a tant dit jamais pourquoi voulez-vous 4
67 ans je commence une carrière de
dictateur
à
vous êtes complice
sur la place du forum chacun le
sentiment que de gaulle non seulement le
comprends mais la pub
c'est
ce qui s'est passé ici
échaudé craint
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
la france considère
que dans toute l'algérie
il n'y a qu'une seule catégorie
d'habitants
il n'y a que des français à part entière
cela signifie qu'il faut reconnaître la
dignité des leçons à qui on l'a contesté
[Applaudissements]
de gaulle est à coup sûr une conviction
profonde c'est celle de la sa légitimité
mais il a toujours besoin de l'avoir
confirmé c'est le sens
de la libération ou le sacre de la foule
à paris le 26 août 1944 lui assure cette
consécration c'est le sens des
référendum mais c'est aussi un niveau
plus modeste le sens d'un certain nombre
de voyages en province où il est à la
foule autour de lui où il serre des
mains et où il a ce sentiment de
l'adhésion des français pour qu'ils
aient un de gaulle il faut être deux il
faut aussi que le pays en concurrence la
france soit prête à le recevoir un de
gaulle et pas pensable aux états unis il
n'est pas pensable en angleterre
la cérémonie de la transmission des
pouvoirs présidentiels au général de
gaulle s'est déroulée suivant un
protocole qui compte parmi les grandes
heures de la république après que le
général catroux lui remis le collier
d'or et des mots de la légion d'honneur
le président coty devait déclarer au
président de la république et de la
communauté monsieur le président
le premier métro c'est
[Musique]
le premier rang
j'étais convoqué avec un des confrères à
l'elysée comme avocate chargée de
demander la grâce de deux condamnés à
mort dans une affaire absolument
dramatique de la guerre d'algérie je
crois la plus dramatique en
1959 et je dois dire que j'étais
absolument paniquer le général de gaulle
ouvre la porte premières impressions
évidemment il est très grand alors
première impression de thoisy me tend la
main bonjour madame dit il et puis il
hésité un moment ils meurent toise et il
me dit madame ou mademoiselle
et tout à coup peut-être un peu paniqué
par pourquoi veut-il savoir qu'est ce
que ça veut dire je lui dis appelez-moi
m et là j'ai senti que de gaulle avait
tout de même le sens de l'humour non pas
qu'ils se soient mis à rire ou un
sourire mais il a hésité un moment il a
dit bien veuillez entrer m et tout au
long de l'entretien il appuiera sur le
mot me diras veuillez vous asseoir m je
vous écoute m et en effet il écoutait et
alors me dit il
ces hommes là qu'ils n'avaient jamais
avoué contre lesquels il n'y avait pas
la moindre preuve dijoux générale
le tribunal militaire n'a pas hésité
mais chez le président il les a
condamnés à mort et
de gaulle de poser quelques questions
très précises
quarante huit heures après 8 heures du
matin coup de fil de l'elysée ils
étaient graciés alors cette entrevue
avec de gaulle a changé dans ma tête
beaucoup de choses et puis par la suite
je me disais tout de même si tout le
monde veut à ce point lui ressemble et
c'est qu'il a marqué la france
devienne la paix des braves
et je suis sûr
que les n
irons danser façon je m'engage
à consulter
les algériens dans leurs douze
départements
au sujet du pépin qu'ils veulent adopter
ayant repris la tête de la france
gm on le sait décidé en son nom de
suivre un chemin nouveau
ce chemin conduit non plus au
gouvernement de l'algérie par la
métropole française mais à l'algérie
algérienne
en reconnaissant le droit de l'algérie à
l'indépendance
une fois de plus de vaud doit se battre
contre son propre camp les éléments de
l'armée se dresse contre lui inversement
des adversaires déterminés de son retour
au pouvoir se rallier à lui
en vérité les seuls antigaulliste
irréductibles sont les nostalgiques de
pétain et ceux qui n'ont pas pardonné à
de gaulle sa politique algérienne
[Musique]
les grands chefs que nous venions
cepal 2 go
mais mme koning général procès le
général n'a su le général single avaient
été des soldats perdus un moment donné
ils avaient désobéi à ce qui était
malgré tout ne pouvoir légal de la
france reconnu par toutes les autres
nations du monde qui était le
gouvernement lui même le pétain de vieux
vainqueur de verdun s'il vient le temps
la notion de ce conflit entre le maire
l'obéissance pour schématiser
nous était un phénomène familier je ne
peux pas dire que le zoo j'ai donné mon
accord au général challe j'ai eu là en
mémoire forcément l'appel du 18 juin
aurait été vraisemblablement un petit
peu prétentieux mais dans notre
inconscient de soldats le fait qu'à un
moment donné un soldat peut être amené à
dire non ce n'est pas possible nous
était une notion familier je dois dire
que contre vous souvenez du référendum
le vernis où il fallait dire est ce que
oui ou non on laisse l'algérie
s'autodéterminer ben la gauche avait été
très divisé on dit jamais oui à de
gaulle moi j'ai dit oui parce que il
m'est apparu que c'était la seule
solution possible à l'étranger mais
endroit particulier en algérie
de gaulle et l'homme
l'homme d'état le plus important pour
les algériens que la france ait connu
parce que c'est vrai qu'il a eu ce
courage mais en même temps j'avais
dénoncé dans une campagne électorale sur
l'ambiguïté parce que l'ambiguïté dont
il a fait preuve n'a pas empêché au
contraire à favoriser je crois la
tragédie des os
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme la preuve est ainsi faite
de la valeur d'une constitution qui veut
que l'êta est une tête
comme depuis que je joue ce rôle
personne n'a jamais pensé que le
président de la république était là pour
autre chose
je crois en toute conscience
que le peuple doit maintenant par un
vote solennel
marqué qu'il veut qu'il en soit ainsi
aujourd'hui demain et plus tard
ainsi deux goals réussi à faire adopter
par les français la réforme
institutionnelle que depuis toujours il
juge indispensable
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel
elle est aujourd'hui encore le pivot de
notre vie politique
une chose qui moi me frappe énormément
derrière les changements qu'il a pu
apporter les changements politiques ou
le changement des institutions il
importait aussi de grands changements
dans le domaine de l'urbanisme et dans
le domaine industriel c'était en fait
quelqu'un de très très moderne et je
dirais très visionnaire je vais prendre
un seul exemple le l'indépendance
énergétique de la france nous étions
nous n'avions pas de pétrole nous
n'avions presque plus de charbon et
c'est lui qui a eu la volonté de
d'imposer ou de convaincre les français
qu'il fallait notre indépendance
énergétique à travers l'énergie
nucléaire et si aujourd'hui 75 % de
notre électricité vient du nucléaire
je peux vous dire que beaucoup de pays
au monde ceux qui comme nous n'ont pas
de ressources de matières premières
beaucoup de pays nous l'envient et ça
c'était un choix du général de gaulle
c'était une aventure étant le peuple
français
il nous faut ou bien accéder au rang
d'un grand état industriel
ou bien nous résigner au déclin nous
avons depuis six ans multiplier par six
les crédits consacrés à la recherche
nous organisons un marché industriel et
agricole commun avec l'allemagne
l'italie la belgique la hollande
luxembourg
nous personne mont blanc nous canalisons
la moselle ne nous unissons à
l'angleterre
pour construire le premier avion de
transport supersonique du monde nous
venons de conclure
avec la russie soviétique
un accord relatif à la mise au point a
et l exploitation de la pensée de
télévision en couleurs
en somme
si grand que soi le verre que l'on nous
tend du dehors
nous préférons boire dans le nôtre tout
en traquant aux alentours
de quitter venait d'être élu président
de la république a voulu la création du
ministère
appelez des affaires culturelles
le 3 février
59 à ce moment-là y avait la guerre
d'algérie il y avait la décolonisation
il y avait un énorme énorme problème qui
se pose est alors dans les problèmes
essentiels
dont vous voulez qu'on sait qu il y
avait la création du ministère qui donne
une liste air de la culture après
l'accueil d'une foule venue nombreuse
sur la route
le président de la république a visité
avec monsieur malraux la maison de la
culture de bourges la plus importante de
force en souhaitant d'autres créations
semblables le général a mis l'accent sur
l'importance de la culture condition
première de la civilisation
ils inaugureront la maison de la culture
de bourges de mouldi la culture domine
tout elle est la condition sinequanone
de notre civilisation d'aujourd'hui
il faut que ce tout ce dont nous
disposons puis se répandre être vu et
entendu par le plus grand nombre
possible
et puis il y avait un deuxième aspect je
crois qui paraît très important a dit
aussi
c'est que l'un et l'autre vers une
vision
de
du monde
c'est pas tous les hommes politiques
avec une vision du monde un séjour à
l'université lomonossov de moscou le
président de gaulle devait notamment
affirmé ceci
culture
science progrès
voilà ce qui à notre époque
au lieu des rêves de conquête et de
domination d'antan
appel et justifie les ambitions
nationales
à coup sûr de gaulle le s'inscrit dans
la grande série des héros de l'histoire
de france le problème c'est la taille
des uns par rapport aux autres je dirais
que
de gaulle
bénéficient de l'histoire qui a été
celle de la plupart de ces héros c'est à
dire des catastrophes et des désastres
suivi de redressement spectaculaire il
incarne une certaine image de la france
avec ce processus d'identification conte
à l'égard des héros mais aussi de
distanciation parce que on se rend
compte qu'on en ait plus du tout là et
de growl suscite une nostalgie il
n'aurait pas beaucoup servi l'europe
s'ils avaient été des apatrides et
qu'ils avaient pensé écrit en quelques
espéranto ouvre la puck intégrer vous
savez je vais vous dire un jour que je
lui ai fait dire dans un dessein aider à
pompidou vous savez ce qui plaît chez
moins en moins pompidou c'est que
j'agace est bon très bien et quelque
temps après je rencontre miral de gaulle
son fils qui me dit
vous avez inventé ça vous avez entendu
mon père le dire généralement je pense
que n'étaient pas gouvernés boulonnais
la france sans gouverner le léman sans
gourde l élite retire je ne connais pas
au camp français
importants qui n'avaient pas un côté
des littératures dans son caractère
mais de gaulle peuvent appliquer les
autres ce parce que son style était très
proche des styles chateaubriand que j'ai
même style fort et là à imaginer qu'il
ait la même temps
réaliste
avec un gisement
40 réduit toujours en supplie
sur son appréciation
les personnes les situations à l'avenir
[Musique]
contrairement à la plupart des héros
nationaux de gaulle est peut-être encore
plus populaire hors des frontières qu'en
france
n'at-il pas développé inlassablement des
thèmes qui sont devenus des évidences
mais qui à l'époque était
révolutionnaire la recherche d'une
troisième voie entre les deux blocs le
refus d hégémonie le droit à l'existence
de chaque nation la nation plus forte
que les idéologies il a prévu
l'écroulement du système soviétique il
parle davantage de la russie que de
l'urss il évoque l'europe de
l'atlantique à l'oural
dans ses périples à travers le monde il
se révèle aussi bons acteurs qu'en
france
est ce une bonne estime dan s les bonis
tech prendre ceci je frappe et le pueblo
frances
rhône alpes web lomé chicanons marché
moss la mano en la mano y viva mexico
à dosettes ainsi
à strasbourg elle grouille bas
si ibra die
in a while she & him
et nous
rallier angers
[Musique]
monde pense
qu'ils les grandes heures de de gaulle
était la libération de la france à mon
avis il est la belle île il marchait
plus loin comme cela ils avaient les
premières
qui a décidé terminé les colonialismes
son discours à brazzaville d'un discours
extraordinaire
avant la fin de la guerre le monde tiers
lui les côtés économique est le côté
social allait même temps
qu'il avait cherché crié
un monde
qui n'est pas occupé
permanente mans entre la concurrence
avec le congrès ans entre les états unis
et l'union soviétique
une chargée en centre social
économique et politique est complètement
différent
l'étape internationale la plus
importante du voyage autour du monde du
général de gaulle restera pour
l'histoire son passage à phnom penh
capitale du cambodge mais principe nous
qu'il accueillait à l'aérodrome avaient
préparé de longue date et dans leurs
moindres détails folklore compris les
fastes du séjour du président de la
république française qui devait dépasser
tout ce que l'on avait vu jusqu'ici en
matière de réception officielle
mais la guerre des 2 vietnam se
poursuivaient à moins de 100 km de là il
n'y a aucune chance
pour que les peuples de l'aide se
soumettre à la loi d'un étranger venu de
l'autre arrive du pacifique quelles que
puissent être ses intentions et quelle
que soit la puissance de 10 ha
bref si l'on dit du que doivent être
encore l'épreuve
il est certain que la france qu'elle
n'aura pas de solution militaire
sur l'ensemble du mouvement de
décolonisation et xixe un bout à l'autre
du monde
je n'ai jamais cessé depuis
le jour même où la guerre mondiale l'a
amené à parler à agir au nom de la
france
je n'ai jamais cessé de suivre la même
direction
considérant que l'émancipation des
peuples
car c'est ça qu'il s'agit
est conforme c'est à la fois au génie de
6 conforme aussi un mouvement
irrésistible
il s'est déclenché dans le monde
nice et toulon des maraudes
gain de trouvères et en une atmosphère
du même genre que celle de la libération
il le québec
québec libre
et quelle est la vérité jusque là voilà
ce qu'il a répondu il a dit j'ai vu une
balance avec deux plateaux dans cette
balance dans l'un des plateaux
disait-il il y avait les anglo saxons il
a fait un geste comme ça pour les
éliminer il a dit de toute façon ils ne
m'aiment pas il y avait toujours dans le
même plateau il y avait les journalistes
lorsqu'ils peuvent écrire scribouille et
raconter ça n'a pas d'importance dans
l'histoire et puis regardant son
interlocuteur et il y avait les gens
comme vous les diplomates alors là il a
fait un énorme geste comme pour les
chasser de la surface de la terre et ils
sont tous assez dans le même plateau
mais dans l'autre plateau at il dit il y
avait le destin d'un peuple je leur ai
fait gagner dix ans alors sur les dix
ans peut-être se trompe et il met cette
phrase résonne encore à mes oreilles je
leur ai fait gagner dix ans je crois
qu'un désavantage de de gaulle c'est que
bien sûr il incarne d'abord et avant
tout le héros français mais son message
dépasse le tas français le message de la
résistance en 40 refus de la défaite le
message ensuite de la décolonisation le
message aussi
du chef d'un pays de dimension moyenne
et qui affirme sa grandeur d'âme à
fabriquer je vais vous montrer
ce que je porte sur moi parce que ça
c'est mon numéro militaire
et ça c'est un verset du coran
d'ailleurs la place et la croix de
lorraine que les annales de gaulle m'a
envoyé
son mode est ainsi un démocrate
heureusement que femme n'oubliez pas
aussi qu'il a pris une position
n'est ce pas
la situation entre nous et l'état
d'israël leurs douars de votre frère il
a pris une position très courageuse
indépendant et de s'autodéterminer
ils étaient des milliers
quelques-uns ne pouvons résister à la
fatigue s'évanouir et ne purent assister
à l'hommage extraordinaire que le monde
entier a voulu rendre par ces rois ces
chefs d'état et de gouvernement au
général de gaulle
m
oh
rien ne montre mieux la personnalité du
général de gaulle que cette cérémonie
incroyable où le monde entier mène le
deuil d'un homme qui a refusé à l'avance
être présents à cette cérémonie
présidents rois princes empereur venus
des cinq continents se regroupent pour
rendre un dernier hommage au général de
gaulle et tous de gaulle et là le
catafalque évident
battre père qui est aux cieux comme ton
nom soit sanctifié
[Musique]
en mai 1968 c'est la cassure entre de
gaulle et une partie de la jeunesse qui
rejetant le vieux monde ne supporte plus
son style
pourtant avec le recul du temps leur
jugement a souvent évolué le philosophe
andré glucksmann a même écrit un ouvrage
de boules oui tu
dans ce qu'aujourd'hui je pense de
négatif du général de gaulle
il reste des éléments de cette époque il
reste par exemple pour les gens de ma
génération
les algériens jetés des ponts en soit en
1961 les morts de charonne aucune
punition fait en ce nom et puis aussi
tout d'une certaine
tout une certaine façon de concevoir le
rapport aux citoyens qui était une façon
très hauts fonds très basée sur la
notion d'autorité même si la sienne
avait une légitimité qui pour nous était
qui aurait été acceptable remettre en
selle de l'homme de la guerre mais pas
celle de l'homme de 58 ans samedi 25 mai
le typhon de l'émeute est passé sur le
quartier latin et la france toute
entière paralysées par les grèves en a
été bouleversée
les menaces du lendemain ont réuni
autour d'une table gouvernement
syndicats et patronat qui discutent en
jour et nuit sans désemparer parviennent
à un projet d'accord aussitôt annoncée
par le premier ministre
le rassemblement du stade charléty
déconseillée par la cgt mais suivie par
certains ouvriers se déroulera et se
dénouera dans l'ordre après dover
suscitée par son importance la crainte
de nouveaux troubles
nous ne croyons pas aujourd'hui que la
violence serait plus large et plus 4 oui
le 29 mai j'ai eu la tentation de me
retirer
et puis en même temps j'ai pensé que si
je partais la subversion menaçant allait
déferler et emporter la république
alors une fois de plus je me suis résolu
c'est vrai qu'à cette époque là les
jeunes voulaient le départ des prés du
général de gaulle
au fond probablement parce qu'il ne
ressentait comme le symbole d'une sorte
d' autoritarisme parental que même subi
c'est dans leur famille royale taux
positifs qui réapparaît le positif c'est
la politique d'indépendance nationale
c'est leur inconscience avec l'allemagne
c'est une certaine
façon de considérer que l'état doit être
au service des citoyens et non pas au
service des factions et
ça ce sont des points qui me semble très
important c'est une question qui avait
calé scandaleuse dit comme ça est ce que
la france est vraiment un pays
démocratique
la france révolution de 89 pays des
droits de l'homme etc ça paraît tout à
fait scandaleux mais étant bien entendu
que la france est un pays d'état de
droit que la france est un pays
républicain et la démocratie c'est autre
chose les démocraties c'est la vie
quotidienne c'est les rapports entre les
gens c'est une façon de s'écouter ce une
façon de négocier les problèmes et
pourrait susciter d'autres pays à
l'heure actuelle où je pense que
l'esprit démocratique
fonctionne mieux c'est ça le problème
c'est est-ce que non non aux tréfonds de
la culture et des mentalités françaises
il a augmenté la quantité de confiance
des citoyens en eux pour régler leurs
problèmes ou est ce que il a augmenté ce
sentiment d'attendre d'un homme
providentiel
c'est une question à laquelle je
répondrai pas mais je crois que c'est en
dehors de tous les aspects bien
évidemment positif au plan international
ou national au plan moi qui m'intéresse
la culture démocratique dans notre pays
c'est la question qui qui qui mois est
fondamentale pour moi d'où mes réserves
la réponse a été non 11 millions neuf
cent soixante six mille français et
françaises ont voté non au cinquième
référendum de la vème république et
jamais dans l'hexagone comme à
l'extérieur n'auraient été ressenti si
fortement l'enjeu d'une décision des
électeurs français au delà d'un problème
intérieur le monde y voit la remise en
cause globale d'une politique pourtant
rien n'est encore joué dans ce sens et
tandis que le président de la république
démissionner merci son âge quand il est
parti
j'avais à l'époque 21 ans dans ma
famille on s'attendait un putsch de de
gaulle
acquis que quelque chose se passe mais
en tout cas je vous avoue qu'on ne
s'attendait pas du tout à la démission
du général qui est parti après ce qu'il
a ressenti comme un désaveu lors de
référendums
[Musique]
c'est depuis l'irlande du sud que le
général de gaulle suit la campagne qui
permettra au français d'élire son
successeur à l'elysée
[Musique]
il a choisi d'aller vivre dans ce pays
d'une beauté sauvage pour marquer sa
volonté de rester étranger à la
compétition qui vient de s'engager en
france pour le pouvoir
c'est très émouvant
et je trouve que fils homo
dans l'histoire française comme des
stars de notre siècle
il joué un rôle extraordinaire il
annonçait une vision complètement
humaine
malgré son côté égocentrique
qui l'avait aussi les capacités pensait
les choses qui sont dehors de lui-même
au départ de l'uimm en eaux profondes
rime à
[Musique]
rien
au lieu de l'esprit français on a
pieusement commémorer
vêtue amina
oh
ça va
les bars
m
[Musique]